[Music]
Mandy Moore reveals Jack and Rebecca's
explosive this is us finale fight hit a
little too close to home and I've got to
say that the fight that you two had was
so incredibly realistic and it really
just highlights everyday struggles that
relationships go through how much do you
find yourself being able to relate to
their relationship unfortunately I
related a little too closely to that
last fight it really touched over for me
could the 32 year old actress be
referring to her marriage with singer
Ryan Adams the two divorced in 2016
she didn't specify what relationship she
was referring to and Mandy is currently
in a relationship with DAWs singer
Taylor goldsmith but she did reveal
she's ready for a Katyn Rebecca musical
duet in season two of her hit NBC show
I'm totally going to push the writers
for the mother-daughter duet in season
two I'm so ready that would be a thrill
I love Chrissie and her voice is just
bananas it's so good would that be so
fun
Chrissy's dream come true yeah that
would be so so much
[Music]